if you don't it will be a massacre we
will lose two battalions
you brought the events of World War 1 to
life Sam Mendes but writing the script
must not have been easy luckily you had
Christie Wilson carbs as an ally but
directing the movie that you did all on
your own
thankfully this wasn't your first time
directing a war film after all you did
direct jarhead in 2005 seriously 1917
would not have been the same without you
were we the only ones that noticed that
you could hear a pin drop while watching
1917 in the movie theaters probably not
1917 was somber and intense and at times
so emotional viewers were weeping in
their seats
this nail-biting movie was filled with
amazing actors terrifying moments in
action sequences so real it felt like
you were in the trenches alongside the
soldiers but like most movies 1917 isn't
perfect although we must admit it's
pretty darn close still it isn't exempt
from goofs plot holes and continuity
errors all of which are easy to miss in
that heat of the moment keep watching to
find out the 15 things you missed in
1917 but keep in mind that this video
contains some major spoilers some men
just want the fight let's kick things
off with a minor plot hold that puzzled
the most attentive of viewers
considering that 1917 is loaded with
computer-generated imagery this mistake
could have easily been avoided if it
hadn't managed to slip past the entire
crew that is when corporal Scofield has
to abandon his truck at hiku after
finding out that the bridge is down she
searches for an alternate route problem
is Scofield finds out that the nearest
bridge is about six miles away from his
current location but when he is later
shown descending the river an intact
bridge can be spotted in the distance
who else spotted this bridge tell us in
the comments you never know
the next thing Ito I'd viewers noticed
is that some factual errors took place
whenever shooting was involved it's not
a huge deal but if you know a thing or
two about the speed of sound it might
have bothered you to some degree when
Scofield is being shot at in the town
several noises just don't add up firing
sounds can be heard in the distance
followed by bullets touching ground but
the opposite should have happened
because bullets travel faster than the
speed of sound
the average bullet travels at 1,700
miles per hour whereas sound itself
travels at 767 miles per hour alright
enough about minor inconsistencies for
now instead let's switch our focus to
the cast of the movie itself 1917 is so
action-packed that it's easy to miss the
lack of females in the film this all
makes sense though considering that
World War one took place from 1914 to
1918 and women didn't start joining the
military until 1948 throughout the film
women can be spotted in photographs but
only two females appear in the movie the
first is the French woman who helped
Scofield and the second is the baby girl
she's caring for this just goes to show
how many men were lost in the great war
after all there were over 16 million
casualties the majority of which were
male soldiers 1917 was not an easy movie
to film and preparation and props proved
to be two of the biggest challenges in
fact actors and extras alike spent a
total of six months rehearsing the movie
before they ever began rolling the
cameras and even then actors collided
with each other by accident while
running through battlefields thankfully
they stayed in character got up and kept
running here's something you might not
know about the war film over 5,200 feet
of trenches were dug for the film that
comes up to just under one mile of
trenches on a side note the lighting rig
that was used for the burning Church
stood 5 stories tall and it was loaded
with 2,000 1 K tungsten lamps it might
surprise you to find out that this
lighting rig is said to be the biggest
one ever built for a movie my brother
Richard Madden is well known for
portraying Robb Stark on the hit TV
series Game of Thrones he was easily
spotted by viewers throughout the film
but the same can't be said about his
game of Thrones co-star Richards
on-screen brother
corporal Blake is played by Dean Charles
Chapman a young yet extraordinarily
gifted actor what I'm saying is that
weight since Dean Charles had a childish
nature about him when he played Tommen
Baratheon in Game of Thrones it's easy
to miss the correlation between these
two actors in Game of Thrones Robb and
Tommen were enemies but in 1917 corporal
Blake will stop at nothing to prevent
his brother from walking into the
enemy's trap while it's a little
ridiculous part of us were scared that
Blake's brother would turn out to be
Joffrey the soldiers who bravely risked
their lives in the Great War were heroes
so it's only fitting that some of the
cast members of 1917 are known for being
heroes themselves but in a very
different way
take Benedict Cumberbatch who plays
colonel McKenzie for example Benedict is
known for portraying Doctor Strange and
Sherlock Holmes
then there's Mark Strong who plays
Captain Smith mark plays the brave agent
Merlin in Kingsman the Secret Service
and if producers had had their way Tom
Holland would have played the role of
Lance Corporal Blake which would have
added the hero spider-man to the mix
however Tom had to turn down the role
due to scheduling conflicts he was a
good man
always telling funny stories if there's
one scene that had us in complete
shambles it's the one where corporal
Blake passes away
Scofield stays by Blake's side as he
takes his final breaths and promises
that he will complete the mission we
watch in complete terror as the color
leaves Blake's face but something about
the scene just doesn't check out
while Blake's face goes white his hands
stay the same color and this continuity
error didn't go unnoticed while we're on
the subject
we'd also like to point out that long
before Blake passes away he suffers an
injury to his neck however when he gets
to the frontline the injury is nowhere
to be found his neck doesn't even have a
scratch or a mark if you consider
yourself a weapon connoisseur you might
have picked up on some subtle errors
throughout the film like when corporal
Scofield is carrying a bolt-action rifle
that requires chambering around before
it can open fire during the scene where
Scofield fires out of window he fires
his weapon two times in a row without
ever chambering a new round another
detail that was overlooked in the movie
revolves around how some soldiers choose
to carry their rifles even sergeant
Sanders made this mistake they carried
their rifles on their left shoulders but
trained soldiers should know better than
to make this mistake
now they soon having more is inside so
it's audio sounds Album 1917 is an
amazing film that is quickly becoming
everyone's favorite war movie but with
so much going on it's only normal that
some details were overlooked throughout
the motion picture did you notice that
the cinematography was on point well
you're not alone and this is thanks to
Roger Deakins of famous cinematographer
who has been spoiling us with his works
of art ever since he stepped out on the
scene anything that Roger touches turns
to gold he's worked as the director of
photography on films like Blade Runner
2049 Skyfall Fargo jarhead and The Big
Lebowski so yeah he's a pretty big deal
if you didn't notice the extent of his
creative genius you'll be able to notice
it when you watch 1917 a second time
they know if they don't shoot the cow
related this tidbit is easy to miss
especially if you aren't well-versed in
the Great War those who have read the
autobiography of Alfred H Mendez know
that this novel is what inspired
director and writer Sam Mendes to take
on 1917 in the first place but did you
know that Alfred HMN Dez was actually
Sam Mendes his grandfather that's right
Sam spent his childhood hearing about
his grandfather's war stories so this
project wasn't near and dear to his
heart
although a lot of plot lines were
dramatized for a good storyline sake a
good portion of 1917 was taken from
Sam's grandfather's memoir sure if
there's one thing that makes 1917 all
the more believable
it's the hundred little details that
help shape the movie everything was
thought about tenfold which helped
immerse viewers even deeper although
this detail slipped by even the most
attentive viewers the Germans noticeably
had higher quality trenches in their
foes and to convey just how disastrous
the Great War had been bodies were left
behind in no man's land to remind
viewers of the many lives that were lost
along the way all these little details
helped shape the world the Great War
took place in I think they wanted us to
go that way they wanted to bury us
depending on how much you know about the
Great War you might have been surprised
to see people of color fighting
alongside Great Britain France in the US
however millions of Indian soldiers
stepped onto the battlefield and sadly
over 74,000 Indian soldiers passed away
as a result after the First Battle of
Ypres took place a soldier named kun da
des Khan was awarded a Victoria Cross
for his bravery and devotion to Great
Britain and three hundred and fifty
thousand African Americans also helped
to win the war so while some viewers
were amazed to see people of color
fighting against the Germans it's wise
to remember that a significant amount of
Indian and African American soldiers
helped Britain France and the u.s. win
the great war one of the things that
makes 1917 so spectacular is how the
movie is filmed it's filmed in a linear
motion as if the entire movie takes
place in a continuing arc that spans
over two hours accomplishing this one
shot look isn't easy but obviously 1917
wasn't filmed in unison forcing the
actors to restart from the very
beginning every time a mistake was made
that would be lunacy to master this
technique a page was taken out of Alfred
Hitchcock's book as he first mastered
the style in the movie rope problem is
while the movie is said to be filmed in
real time the course of the movie sees
daylight nighttime and daylight once
more so there's no way the movie took
place throughout a two-hour time frame
not all movies are created equal but we
can all agree that 1917 is a timeless
flick that will forever be at the top of
our lists however there's one major plot
hold that viewers can't seem to get over
and it revolves around a certain letter
Schofield jumps into a river to escape
German soldiers and he remains in the
water for several minutes but
considering the era and the ink used to
write that letter the ink would have
been faded destroying the letter in the
process and yet the letter miraculously
remained legible hey Jeff yes
stand them down did you realize that
both Blake and Schofield have the same
first name and that their names were
only revealed at the end of the movie on
a side note did anyone notice that 1917
ends and begins in a similar fashion the
only difference is that at first
Schofield and Blake are shown side by
side whereas in the final scene only
Schofield remains did you notice
anything that we didn't tell us in the
comments at Schofield William Schofield
for more videos like this one don't
forget to subscribe to the things and be
sure to give this video a big thumbs up
too we'll see you next time thanks for
watching